[Music]
all right what's up y'all I am in Seoul
Korea you're at the Incheon Airport yeah
we're with the chance am waiting for a
layover connect a flight to Hong Kong
yeah it's actually Christmas dating here
so we missed out on a Christmas Eve we
spent Christmas Eve in the airplane it's
technically Christmas Eve back home so I
kind of feel like this Christmas Eve for
me but yeah with all the time different
time change and all that stuff it gets
confusing but yeah Merry Christmas
this looks like a mall this is a lot an
airport this is the law
[Music]
[Laughter]
very deserted
[Music]
so we decided to get korean french
picking i guess if you only have like an
hour to spend Anna Karenina port Korean
fried chicken is a pretty good option
for a little quick snack this is a big
one
spicy good he said it was really spicy
he may just buy a water just cuz he was
like it's very spicy
I see how spicy it come on you're a hot
cheetos Pro the spice someone really
creeps up on you
it just gets the spicier and spicier
notice over these layers this is
specifically this year I can't even talk
I'm all just burning up my body can't
handle spicy anymore so now when I eat
spicy food I got a stomach ache and now
I know what it feels I never understood
when people be like you poop like fire
I've never understood that I feel like
this fraction we just say might just do
that when the worst combination of that
is to be in the flight I'm doing I see
you didn't have an idea the guy that
keeps eating and goes it's not true
spikey it's not spicy but then he goes
it's too spicy he's like alright where
we go now we're heading up to Hong Kong
now we are done here at our state
[Music]
long trip to get here
like Marines I know
really didn't like
you know I'm so excited I've been here
once before but that was like four years
ago resuming in my face
what do you know about Hong Kong what is
like your idea of Hong Kong right now
it's like a
excited to see all the girls they have a
busy one here oh yeah Disneyland
the Shanghai
[Music]
you don't blend in
in a really long time it was really a
long time are we even going to the
Mediterranean like even though I think
we'll blend in more than I can it's
tricky look you started really look like
you'd some butter you posted about you
look like a teenager and you guys were
together I'm like I could get now I
didn't see it before but neither
[Music]
there's
[Music]
[Music]
really doing put it here though I'm
jealous I think I said leg
[Music]
Varian smell smells like Chinese fruit
punch down this aisle it smells good
durian and jackfruit mixed together with
some news online
[Music]
yeah diamond.i you're gonna have Isis
police station famous why this because
of all the corruption the police force
been in the 70 60s and 70s I thought it
was because they were it was in the
movies
oh yeah they use it in the movie a lot -
yes okay
oh the Hong Kong make gangs the movie
you see this building
[Music]
he works here it's a real person oh okay
we're can be sensation where all the
street is they're demolishing the
building
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my favorite God on classic Hong Kong
street food hung on waffles curry fish
balls
one thousand two hundred and ten dollars
for probably rails for that one
[Music]
it's so funny because in our cupboard
ammo in the kitchen there's a thing it's
not this obviously but there's a product
in there that smells like this and I'm
pretty sure it's pretty pricey and TIFF
always complaints about how smelly it is
and wants me to throw it out but now
that I've learned how much this could
possibly be in my pantry definite now
and I should probably know why I soon
found one even more expensive
[Applause]
that's what I was like a pantry right
sounds like tamarind
no don't worry about it our country oh
this is what we have at home this is
what smells in our house what is it
scallops I think
[Music]
we're on the ferry or main island all
right
40 years ago we were sitting this same
boat basically and mommy was sitting
here I was sitting here and the guy in
front of me open the newspaper and then
what I saw was we were seeing a tie and
that shocked me and I was only like what
14 years
[Music]
good morning
it's our second day in Hong Kong or on
the move we heading to breakfast last
night was rough man
Lag kept waking up like a 3m Emporium
how did you sleep pretty good Oh
you was exhausted last night
she was dead just like there was no way
we're gonna convince Isaac
get on the ferris wheel but Isaac was
too tired and then a lot of us were
tired too so we ended up just calling it
an early night and then we went home
plate comes in Nintendo switch and I
went to sleep but right now we're
heading over to meet Iman and we just
came on and uncle we're gonna have
breakfast and then the only other thing
I know about today is that Carrie was
getting his hair braided I don't know
what like what's all that about but
that's happening
he has an appointment to get his hair
braided and then
or just Hong Kong it even though it's
like it's gorgeous in a like dirty way
we're just like a funky can away
it has its own beauty you know I really
like the city like Hong Kong baby what
do you think about the city of Hong Kong
I like it how does it compare to New
York it's more dirtier no no so many
people - last night I think I almost got
crushed
we're and record record that I know I
see it you who is in front of me and
we're trying to get to the harbor and
then set the crosswalk sideways
Christmas celebration every was trying
to get to the harbor and we were all
like please like sorry there I did me of
New Year's even in New York again I'm
I'm like I legit was like rush like it
was so hard for me to take you - Marie
that one for you has anybody been dumped
in the river because
that many people I don't know probably
I'm pretty sure a lot of people have
accidentally fallen I was telling her
about you know the meeting of Hong Kong
Oh what is that the work Hong in candy
and say
or chamois menu
yeah era madam you smell good the reason
they call this play Hongkong smell good
harbour actually that's one of me I
smell good harbour it because it smelled
its thing in the past like two hundred
years ago this thing place because I'm
all the fish
Hong Kong definitely has a very
and I can't describe
like cumin was like a little bit of
garbage
like like super like super smell with
like the combination of things and then
like all the lights and all the people
like your senses are definitely just
experiencing a lot when you're here
really
[Applause]
stomping grounds right here how does it
feel to be back in your hood it's
different this but it wasn't there it
was in there but I remember this
building it this bit sorry they're just
told me something about you and Papa do
you remember this bus stopped school bus
stop around this area yeah
not here in there so I will I take my
site I get on the school bus for mr.
Koerner and then he's supposed to get on
the bus alert the one before before me
and he will walk all the way there to
talk to me
and then I
we're eating breakfast mom breakfast at
a time thing with FG g t restaurant cafe
yeah
[Music]
we are at a very very woman's favorite
right here in Hong Kong and my dad says
is one of the better Hong Kong selfies
he's ever had
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can't City and I gotta get my own
light a must have when you're here you
ordered some peanut butter french
I got a smoke favorite hot milk please
goal number two
[Music]
all right so here right now here at the
place my brother's gonna get his hair
braided why do you want to get your hair
braided because it's not every day I can
have my hair braided and so at home like
why I'm here
oh because this vacation does that hole
have to work you know something now I
know I'm often I spend time from our
vacation to get your hair yeah I had
great it was for Halloween but you know
it had to happen what that specifically
does African style grades here which i
think is pretty cool so in Hong Kong
yeah so I want to try that out so when
my brother first told me that he wasn't
getting hair braided I thought you were
going to do like a like a Hong Kong
style way of braiding hair but
apparently it's African style alright so
we're in the building where Kerry he's
gonna get his hair braided but we got
here way too early we have to kill about
20 minutes so we're up on the 26th floor
because I declare to come to the top so
we're in the bathroom right now we're
not anywhere not even resume or noise
and there it'll be suppose like how this
became about one of our destinations on
this trip it's really cool because we
wanted to see outside the window and
area took a peek and it's this is a
pretty cool view was oh look at that
look at that over there
[Music]
all right so my brother's
[Music]
[Music]
transformations like a Japanese driver
yeah like this yeah
[Music]
all right so now we are here visiting
[Music]
she gave me this bracelet number our
wedding I was actually there when she
gave the bracelets to your mom - mom
because we get to two bracelets over
each let me get married we're actually
having been some and she like robbed the
knowledge it was like oh here it's like
for when you get married I don't know -
batchi when they would have make it to
the wedding business travel is too heavy
for her but I was there when she gave it
to you guys and then we actually had it
I've been through the wedding
[Music]
remember when you're a little on we
would have been some use any of anything
like any of it probably our adventures
we've prepared him for this trip it was
six years in the making
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know how and photo-editing there's
the contrast I know the contrast is like
blown out right now because it's like
it's too faded right now or like on
Instagram the Facebook or a smoggy day
oh yeah smoggy days this is what el la
looks like on a bad day it's true it's
all soggy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh this place is fine okay finally
something fun what are you doing over
there
modeling
[Music]
[Music]
for you this all right so now we are
eating and this social place so I'm
super excited about this dinner because
every time you come to Hong Kong with my
parents we always end up eating super
traditional very very traditional very
non Instagram Abul I gave this more for
your taste buds to enjoy resident the
camera and for once eleni eleni alerted
[Music]
and on our plate
yeah we did a lot of walking down
[Music]
and unlike all the other restaurants
here produced they have really really
funky seats so comfortable being under
vegan tells a grouchy
[Music]
I'm tired
alright this I've never seen before
sweet and sour pork
looks like buns that look like
all right so tip is not feeling very
good but she wants to see for you
exciting great apple sauce on the inside
[Music]
like a mushroom all right this is not
like truffles should pop you mushrooms
and truffle oil
[Music]
[Music]
all right about the use of a Porky Pig
right here
Oh purple sweet potato all right so I
had a great meal stay some food for tip
and Isaac because they're gonna be
eating leftovers later tonight
wait for my team maybe leprosy or the
night and was just tomorrow tomorrow
[Music]